[Musique]
le conseil de classe d'isabelle
morini-bosc on rappelle que vous pouvez
bien sûr voter ou aussi acheté pmp
conseils de classe et vous nous donnez
la docte pour isabelle genre isabelle on
va faire un récapitulatif de ce que vous
avez fait en ce début d'année
comment vous êtes vous vous êtes senti
vous alors déjà là je déteste cette
classe rappelle mon primaire qui comme
vous le savez ne m'a pas réussi et
comment je joue mon année comment vous
voilà ce que vous êtes senti bien
pendant ce ses premiers mois ben moi je
me sens toujours bien parce que
j'adorais clamart en tant que spectateur
d'accord certains certaines fois
certaines fois je vous ai trouvé attaché
ans ouais et plus pour le reste est
tabou mais vous vous êtes trouvé comment
moi je me trouve jamais hein je me
trompe jamais jamais isabelle morini
bosc
c'est avant tout deux passions les
médias et la danse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu
voilà elle est enfant des chorégraphies
durant lesquels elle donne tout vraiment
tout ça a été la tuer mais là dedans ce
n'est pas le seul talent caché
d'isabelle c'est aussi une imitatrice à
rendre jaloux nicolas canteloup ses
meilleurs sketches cyril comme vous
diriez cyril gilles verdez c'est
toujours la même chose et n'est pas
chaleureux et les médias et même jean
marie le pen bron oui on comprend
isabelle c'est aussi un humour corrosif
qui met bien l'ambiance on a fait des
soirées à thème soirée mattrick on
essaie igor et grichka des anecdotes
toujours aussi passionnante et sinon moi
j'ai beaucoup sauvés alors en revanche
des buses et des aigles avec mon père en
avait trop sortir des pièges de
braconniers
j'arrive dans les grands magasins les
sapins sont installés excusez-moi 500
dénommé 3 au bar du quartier
attention tout de même aux accrochages
avec les lettres verdez
ça te qu'on découvre ce qu'ils ont donné
tout ça mais
bref isabelle vous signez un bon premier
trimestre alors qu'est ce qu'on peut
vous souhaiter pour le deuxième
j'aime sa grande gueule toute une soirée
pour moi je trouverai pas dans ce navire
est orné
[Applaudissements]
matt dillon europe tu aimes bien
isabelle ben c'est vrai tu la quittes je
sais il a un très beau ah ouais c'est
assez spécial je serai un peu de chaleur
l'expliqué sur le crâne ouais c'est quoi
votre théorie du cran quand on a un
crâne parfaitement rond et lisse comme
le sien avec une jolie nuque c'est
dommage de [ __ ] une casquette dessus
bah ouais c'est ça ça c'est vrai c'est
pas dans la nature et ses latéraux il y
aurait de la casquette sur le crâne et
toi parions qu'il aime bien isabelle
ouais je les adore elle est l unique
personne qui dit alors on va voir les
notes
attention on va démarrer par kevin alors
moi j'ai mis 6 sur 10 alors je me suis
surtout avec les points fort pertinente
joyeuse autodérision travail est aussi
une capacité à jouer le jeu
par exemple à l'extérieur avec les lots
sur les cheveux etc en fait vous avez 90
un peu j'aurais pas faire et points
faibles trop systématiquement toujours
pour son groupe avec la belle chanson
cdi qu'on connaît voilà m6 trop 3
couragement encouragements pas mal donc
tu as mis combien
si c'est pas mal je sais pas
mazza moi tu as tout bon tu es
l'encyclopédie universalis de tpm peut
tuer un puits de science du paf tu est
extrêmement gentil alors la gentillesse
c'est ringard mais moi j'adore tue aussi
la plus polie d'entre nous police as
écrit p o à l'icis a pour matthieu
delormeau ses recherches dans des causes
que ça veut dire
enfin l'ue s'est pris une balle perdue
ses bottes
j'aime tout de toi j'aime tes silences
gmt décibels j'aime quand tu parles sur
les gens voilà j'aime tout alors en
revanche tu as un énorme point fait
bizarre c'est que tu subis tu subis les
cris de gilles tu subis les chatouilles
de mathieu tu subis les réflexions sur
ton âge sur ton absence de saint sur les
panna cotta l'epa panna cotta stop on
voit tout boulet et surtout à le tuer
n'oublie pas que tu la seule à avoir un
cd autour de la table c'est peut-être
parce qu'on était la meilleure
j'ai mis un très beau c'est tennessee
quand même
ah ouais ah oui c'était me savuth avait
déjà laissé savoir dans le dos tous les
périls arrive dans le dos isabelle
j'aime ta spontanéité j'aime ton sens du
détail et ta bonté aussi envers les
autres télés la séductrice et tu sait
mettre en valeur au sida féminité et on
lance olivier rarement je le vois tu
aussi un centre de la diplomatie qui
joue largement en sa faveur
notamment lorsque tu es et tu es sûr
touche pas à mon poste tu réponds
toujours vous présente lorsque tu as le
soutien des uns et des autres petit
bémol qui n'en est pas forcément 1 200
que cette année plus particulièrement tu
as envie d'être admiré et tu as envie
d'être aimé plus que tout mais technique
on t'aime on a un grand coeur pour ça et
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai nommé
fin de la belle contrée de classes
populaires allez les bons à moïse à bell
ya un truc que j'aime bien ma vie c'est
comme d'haïti narbonne enfant gâté la
manière de dire bonjour quand les gens
te disent bonjour tu le fait j'adore
comment tu lui bonjour j'adore comment
géraldine me dire bonjour je te trouve
sincère je te retrouverai avec les
téléspectateurs terrain personnages
emblématiques de touche pas à mon poste
ça on peut rien dire les vrais avec les
gens aussi il ya un seul truc que
j'aimerais bien moi c'est qu'une fois tu
te défonces une fois une émission de m6
voir comment ça fait c'est juste que je
te demande et ensuite pas je vais faire
court j'aimerais être content si
j'aimerais que ça continue qu'on
s'envoie des textos le matin à 6 heures
du matin parce que je t'écoute aussi à
la radio à 6 heures du matin et je te
trouve excellente
et les mecs qui l'a 36 un coup même si
c'est une très bonne j'aime pas trop
bonnes feuilles del alamo sa vie alors
oui la note oui la note je suis troublé
qui l avait pas de toit mais fine alors
- isabelle taffin je te jure je te le
dis bravo
aujourd'hui cette page c'est beaucoup
mieux que d'habitude c'est ça fait
puissance que je suis souvent en retard
en fait elle se prépare mieux alors
isabelle donc tu es très travailleuse ça
tu le sais tout le monde le sait tuer
énormément d'humour ça c'est très
apprécié et tu as une implication totale
service que total d'ailleurs ça en l'air
en laponie s'appelle une conscience plus
que pro je suis allé quand vers la
mondiale l on écrit au total merci
maxime voilà alors je sais que tu ne te
reposes josh gorges ou parce que tu
travailles beaucoup et on a envie de te
garder que nous le plus longtemps
possible c'est pour ça que je t'invite à
te reposer c'est pour ça que je voulais
pas n'importe quelle retraite entre les
doigts mais à cette juste pour avoir un
tout petit peu plus le temps prendre le
temps de te reposer parce que c'est très
important
bravo
allez on va passer sa rivale à la sa
rivale on va faire d'avoir cali
apprendre à sa rivale et bien moi c'est
ma mine d'amour que j'aime vraiment avec
grande sincérité on a appris à se
découvrir en laponie
sincèrement non réellement la poigne et
je trouve parce qu'on a passé de supers
bons ressorts et j'ai su apprécier tous
ces moments dans nos discussions et de
nos petits cadeaux et comme ça et par
contre je trouve quand pato tu cries
beaucoup trop bas je pense fragile c'est
comme ashley gilles juste en face de moi
il rejoint sa tête ça me fait de la
peine
donc pour ça je te mets 1,6 mais je
t'aime d'avant allez on va passer à
mathieu alors isabelle contrairement à
moi tu n'as que des défauts ma chérie tu
parle tout le temps tu es à côté la
techno dirais-je de fontès et pénible
turrado tout le temps qu'ils étaient
comestibles quand un beau maquillage
36,15 qui n'en veut les mêmes vannes
depuis sept ans une fringue comme un
arbre de noël même en juin tu fillon dit
la vérité tu es jaloux de desmaures aux
jaloux bien évidemment donné aujourd'hui
les loges bien sûr tu sens que la petite
jeune pousse derrière
[Rires]
tullett tout temps l'agent l'adea pouf
pouf pouf pour montrer que tu est souple
et que ça il va encore le week-end nous
fait croire que tu me trouves pas
forcément une personne n'y croit bref on
pourra quand tu quand tu parles tu crois
moi un bon c'est bien croire au père
noël on apprend plein de choses c'est
pas le problème
voilà quand on parle de m6 évidemment tu
es totalement bonbons n'a jamais on n'a
jamais la vérité bref mais pour faire un
rap un ratio avec ce que j'aime la
course automobile
un jour il ya un grand critique de
voiture qui a été voir la skyline gt-r
que d'une voiture formidable et une
ferrari
ils essaient la voiture japonaise elle a
aucun défaut et laisser les ferrari que
les défauts alors je n'étudie vous
choisissez la skyline gt-r et répond non
justement
je choisis la verite la ferrari parce
que dans la vie ce qui est intéressant
ce sont les défauts c'est pour ça que ma
chérie je te met huit jours
bon en tout cas je suis et je fais une
biture question directe au sud la
bataille est vite fait allez on va
passer maintenant à sa rivale hillary
diène sont ils sont deux mais elles sont
d'aujourd'hui mais c'est vrai qu'à la
petite jeune aujourd'hui sur les deux
sur le plateau
et vous savez aussi mais ne pourront
rester qu'une non à ben je sais hausse
et on sait qu'il ya une certaine
rivalité entre vous deux kurdes ont
attaqué mais a way pour le sait ça voilà
on va pas sortir j aimerais pas de
langue de bois ici un pas de langue de
bois ici c'était la même chose quand il
y en a reçu geneviève de fontenay est là
les deux on sait c'est là une petite
rivalité à la guerre vous allez nous
donner votre appréciation
je veux que vous soyez franche ouais
parce qu'on sait exactement ce que vous
pensez d'isabelle on fera on mettra un
bémol mais on sent que ça degré accord
attention c'est parti il n'en restera
qu'une alors commence par les points
forts isabelle tuer l'âme la mémoire
vivante de tpm paix tu es un courage
physique exceptionnel d'abord parce que
t'es à côté de gilles depuis des années
et ça fait honteux ce coup dans tous les
sens enfin tourner honte honte tu as tu
reçois de l'eau tu ne dis rien donc pour
la phase aller tu reçois pour ton
courage exceptionnel jeter valls est ton
point fort alors évidemment il ya des
points faibles
quoi qu'en pensent certains je
t'apprécie énormément fait et c'est pour
ça que je m'inquiète pour toi parce que
quand je vois un oeil à 8 heures le
matin tu en est déjà à sa quatrième
chronique sur rtl
quand je ferme le soir et bats toi tu
commences à regarder des téléfilms
pendant que à l'indoor on rêvant à des
monceaux de panna cotta
donc tu travailles trop isabelle vas-tu
un mari je n'en ai pas tu as un enfant
je n'en ai pas le veux tu as aidé
tu as cdi je n'en ai plus donc il est
temps peut-être de prendre un petit peu
de repos donc je te donne un très beau 5
d'encouragement à prendre ta retraite
bien méritée elle sait bien mais elles
sont toutes sur les mêmes dossiers dès
qu'il ya un mec depuis 85 ans et son
dauphin cyril c'est ça voulait dire que
en fait on fait souvent l'émission
ensemble et ça c'est vous seriez vous
vous en fichez de l'âge du physique
non non non ce que vous voyez c'est la
personnalité la beauté intérieure et
pour ça
[Applaudissements]
à votre intérieur à la beauté intérieure
on s'en fout que je sois dit delphine
est tout autre c'est vrai c'est une
bagarre d'une très belle personne alors
vous évader l'intérieur aussi c'est pour
ça que je vous ai choisis
merci c'est trop jean-marie et extérieur
également si vous êtes de plus en plus
beau jeu et rendez vous chez l'ophtalmo
l'avant ses quarante ans d'être physique
de ceux du conte est allé me dont il
avait le merci d'abord cette nuit j'ai
fait une insomnie et au lieu de compter
les moutons j'ai compté vos défauts 202
203 104 me suis endormie comme un bébé
vous êtes formidables isabelle mais
c'est vrai que vous avez quand même des
points forts vous êtes une camarade de
table ultra sympathique mais une
chroniqueuse cataclysmique
c'est plus possible de continuer comme
ça tout m6 est formidable toutelatélé
formidable vous n'avez aucun avis
critique sur rien si maxime guény
faisaient ça trois jours il serait à
l'agonie est viré et cette attention
parce que tati
je vais vous donner une de mes
meilleures notes que j'ai jamais donné
sept ans que nous sommes l'un à côté de
cela et nous nous voyons des plus que
nos conjoints c'est pour ça peut-être
qu'ils continuent à nous supporter cette
c1 chiffres merveilleux il appelle set
mais c'est pas votre notaire était un
zéro pointé isabelle mais parce que j'ai
énormément de respect pour la femme
merveilleuse que vous êtes je vous donne
un je me permets de vous offrir ce
bouquet droit
[Applaudissements]
la note est plutôt 5,8 sur 10 6,2 pour
les chroniqueurs vous avez une moyenne
de 7 sur 10 isabelle vous vous classez
vous êtes combien dans la classe pour
l'instant bien la distance et celle de
classe de gilles verdez bas vous êtes
deuxième vingt les premiers de la classe
pour l'instant bravo isabelle
morini-bosc aux témoignages merci mon
coeur